Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
[Silence]
in
authored by
the chapter of patience
narration number 48 on on the authority
of Abi
who narrates that a man said to the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam advise me
to which he responded do not become
angry and so the man repeated his
request
and upon each time the prophet
sallallahu alaii wasallam would repeat
do not become angry. This narration has
been collected by Imam Bkari. We've
mentioned before
that this statement
is largely
a type of a a rhetoric that is used a
type of speaking that
articulates exaggeration
in the particular
statement. So what does that mean? A
person is not in control of what makes
him angry. He's not in control of what
makes him happy largely. A person is not
in control of who he loves. He's not in
control of who he naturally dislikes
etc. As the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
would say in the narration of
that the prophet Sam
would be
very just with his wives and he would
then say, "Oh Allah, this is what I am
able to do. So do not hold me to account
for that which is out of my control."
meaning love, meaning that he may love
one more than the other in his heart,
not in his actions.
A person having a natural or
dislike, anger, happiness, pleasure,
etc. These are things that are largely
out of a person's hand.
However, when the prophet sallallah.aii
alaihi wasallam prohibits that. It means
do everything in your power not to
become angry
including what leads to anger and
including your response to anger. It's
kind of where Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says.
He says, "Do not die except in a state
of Islam." Death is not something I
control. It's not something you control.
How is it that Allah is prohibiting us
from doing something or commanding us to
do something that is not in our control?
[Silence]
asb said, "Do not die except as
Muslims."
meaning live upon Islam in your days of
health and in your days of ease so that
you may die upon it. Because when a
person lives upon something, he will die
upon that thing. And whoever dies upon a
particular thing will be resurrected
upon that thing. And so the scholars of
Islam tell us that this statement of the
prophet
It means two main things. Number one,
do not do things or put yourself in a
situation that will lead to your
inevitable anger.
Right? Number two is that if a person
becomes angry that they are to control
themselves. That a person is to control
himself at his time of anger. As we will
hear in a later narration
that the truly strong is not the one who
can who can wrestle people to the
ground. Rather the truly strong is the
one who is able to control himself in
times of anger. Now when we look through
the Quran if we look in the Sunnah of
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam.
We see that
the prophets and messengers would become
angry. We see that the prophet Muhammad
sallall.aii wasallam has become angry.
But there's a difference between their
anger and the anger which is prohibited
here in this narration from two aspects.
Number one, what they would become angry
about.
They didn't become angry over silly
things. There's too much salt in their
food. They felt somebody looked at them
wrong. They didn't appreciate this or
that or they felt they were owed
something they weren't given or someone
spoke to them. This is not how the
prophets and messengers would become
angry or pleased. Rather the prophets
and messengers they would become angry
for
worthy reasons. Misam
Allah praises him in the Quran for his
anger. Why? because of why he became
angry that Musam when he came back to
his people he found them worshiping a
calf made of gold not all of them but a
large portion of them and that they had
disobeyed Harun and that they had
threatened to kill Harun
if he got in their way and Mus Alisam
became so angry that he threw the
tablets that Allah had given him down
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala praises
him for his anger for this issue.
He praises him for his anger for this
issue and this is why he mentions it to
us subhanahu wa ta'ala because this is
worthy of a person's anger
has said about our prophet Wasam.
[Silence]
She said
that the prophet would never take
vengeance
over a personal issue
unless a boundary of a law and a
prohibition had been crossed.
And if it came to the prohibitions of
Allah and the boundaries of Allah, there
is no stopping his vengeance
for the sake of Allah. And so we see
another instance of our prophet becoming
angry when a woman was of a high
tribe. She was of of you know of of
higher lineage in Medina. And she was
the way this woman did things is she
would ask to borrow
things from people and then when she
would borrow the things
valuable things not petty things people
would come and ask for their property
she would deny that they ever gave her
anything.
And so the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam
had it was raised to him and he had
judged that her hand be cut off for for
stealing.
And so she was of a high ranking tribe
member, right? This is not just any
old person. So the companions debated
whether or not to send someone to try to
intercede on her behalf to try to ask
for some leniency
they figured the best person to send to
him would be Z.
And then when he came to the prophet
sallallah alaii wasallam the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam became very angry
and he said
He said to him rhetorically, "You are
interceding
with regards to a boundary of Allah and
a judgment of Allah."
And then he said to the people
[Silence]
He then said, "Oh people, I swear by
Allah that if Fatima,
the daughter of Muhammad were to have
stolen
that no one would cut her hand off but
[Arabic recitation]
Why? Because this is worthy of a
person's anger. This is anger which is
praiseworthy. As a matter of fact, this
is anger that if you don't have it,
something is wrong.
Something is deeply wrong with a person
and deeply flawed if they do not become
angry for the sake of Allah. If they do
not become pleased for the sake of
Allah. If they do not become jealous for
the sake of Allah. This is how the
prophets and messengers are. If a person
is just cool, cool as a cucumber,
nothing rocks his boat. Whether Allah is
disobeyed or obeyed, whether Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala's religion excels
or doesn't, whether the prophet sunnah
is trampled on or not, but he's cool as
a cucumber. This is someone, this is
someone who has deeply flawed morals.
[Arabic recitation]